i kind of use five words that drive me
and it's uh think create relate give and
move
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we
are talking with david york and this is
going to be a really fun conversation
david is an attorney and cpa who
practices law in the area of estate
planning with extensive experience in
designing advanced strategies for high
net worth clients
david has spoken to hundreds of public
groups and professional organizations
including tedx salt lake city hugh
commons the hawaii tax institute the
purposeful planning institute
investments in wealth institute valmark
member summit southeastern family office
forum and the million dollar roundtable
david has also written three books
entrusted riveted and the gift of lyft
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're gonna have some really
interesting conversation and i feel like
you know perhaps some things that that
people may think we're gonna talk about
they're gonna take a little bit of a
pivot right and left which is gonna be
pretty awesome and but but i i want to
get started david by understanding a
little bit of what you do and then we'll
get to to some of the more interesting
stuff regarding your philosophy and then
how you see you know people but
what is really a state management and
wealth management and what what is it
that you do in the day to day
yeah so my day job i'm a i'm attorney
i'm also a cpa
and i focus in the areas of estate
planning tax planning asset protection
charitable organizations so
my background is very uh on the
technical side on the transactional side
uh helping people in the course of that
been fortunate enough to get to work
with a lot of entrepreneurs uh a lot of
family businesses
and a lot of high net worth and ultra
high net worth people
and so if you're looking at your work
with these types of people in these
types of organizations and how does that
work actually take place is it mainly
you know a decision has been made and
you're coming and you're helping them
execute on that decision is it
consulting for that decision which part
of the process are integrated with
yeah estate planning is really the
process of creating structures
uh to hold manage and pass wealth um so
similar just like a corporation uh you
have to have corporate documents and
things like that on the estate planning
side um one of the unique elements of
capitalism is that people have to own
things right and so how do you own them
and then how do you transfer the
ownership of that and how do you do that
in a tax efficient way and asset
protected way so
you know my my background where i came
from was on a much more
uh
structural standpoint uh at least
initially
interesting
along the lines you developed these
different ideas and philosophies
regarding you know things that are
specifically related to to it to estate
management and wealth management but not
necessarily also just a little bit about
you know how the world works and how
different organizations are run tell me
a little bit about that yeah like i said
during the course of doing this i've
gotten to work with uh i've had over 6
000 clients and in the course of that a
lot of just you know
mom and pop raising their kids uh but a
lot of entrepreneurs uh who i find to be
some of the most unique and talented and
quite frankly
uh troubled individuals you know they
tend to be more extremes uh and there's
just something wonderful
what word you were gonna use and and i'm
glad you said troubled yeah
yeah and that's not just anecdotal i
mean the reality is uh they did a study
uh among entrepreneurs and um
they found that um
uh entrepreneurs twice as likely to
suffer from depression as the general
public six times were
six times more likely to have adhd
three times more likely to deal with
substance abuse
11 times more likely than the general
population to be bipolar
uh
yeah and even among um
those who don't have a self
self-diagnosed issue or struggle
they're twice as likely to identify as
coming from families with mental issues
uh as others so
yeah they just and and when you think
about it actually makes sense they tend
to be more extreme right they tend to be
more extreme in
uh their work ethic and how they view
life and their perspective and their
engagement and all those things and
um and they they've they did another
study that only about eight percent of
the population is entrepreneurial and i
think that's one of the biggest myths is
we think anyone can become an
entrepreneur but the reality is it's
just a fairly unique subset of people
who look at life differently and see
life differently than everyone else and
so you know as i'm doing all this estate
planning and everything else i started
to notice like the characteristics and
habits of of people who are the most
impactful
but you also had some interesting
insights regarding at the end happiness
levels and fulfillment and
you know different forms of you know why
people do things
why do organizations do things and how
how these things come together right
yeah you know i think that's one of the
we all start with certain assumptions
and i started in estate planning with a
fairly
you know i thought was a true assumption
which is
money equals happiness right the more
money you have the happier you are and
so as you head up the wealth continuum
um
you're going to see people with
increasing levels of happiness and that
was one of the things i did not see
in fact what i saw was more of an
inverted u-curve in the correlation
between the amount of uh wealth that
people have and the relative perceived
levels of happiness and you know and
this is actually backed up empirically
they they did a study uh that showed
that as you make more money you tend to
have higher levels of happiness but only
up to a certain point and then that
starts that high that point right no in
the us it's about 95 000 now yes palo
alto is probably more than salt lake
city but you know there's different
levels but you know they looked at
reasons why and obviously some are kind
of intuitive like it takes more work and
effort to make more money you know just
uh more time uh
two
uh is social comparison that's one of
the biggest ones is as you get more
money you start to look around at what
other people have and unfortunately it
becomes more about what other people
have and what you don't have than what
you actually have
uh
but then the third was the most
fascinating and it correlates to that
number and what they found was
at about 95 000 in the u.s
you can get everything you need
so then you switch to what you want
and need is actually
fairly quantifiable but want is
insatiable you know you can always have
the faster car the bigger house the
nicer trip whatever and so you start to
chase a mirage
uh and that actually leads to
dissatisfaction and some of the most
content people are the ones who just all
they have is what they need uh and they
get out of that hedonic
uh treadmill of constantly seeking the
next shiny thing
wow
and this ties back to the why
yeah yeah and so what was interesting is
i was dealing with clients all the way
along the wealth continuum you know
whether they're worth a hundred thousand
or a billion dollars
you know i i could see people who uh had
a level of engagement
uh and purpose
that it had nothing to do with how much
money they had in the bank and so i
started to look at that and the
probably the seminal experience i had
was about six years ago
i was working with uh the owner of the
utah jazz uh her name's gail miller she
owned one of the 30 nba franchises one
of the wealthiest women in the united
states completely self-made and we were
working on a trust that would transfer
and keep the the jazz in the in the
state of utah indefinitely and so i just
out of hand we were reviewing some
documents and i asked her i said how
will it feel to no longer own the jazz
uh and uh but i thought that was a
fairly simple question and she looked up
at me and she said well i don't own the
jazz
and she went back to looking at her
documents and here i am i'm the estate
planning lawyer and you know i'm
i'm you know she's such a bright smart
person but i felt like i had to say
no
actually you do own the jazz you know
you're the owner of the jazz and i'll
never forget what she said she stopped
what she was doing she looked at me and
she said no
i'm a steward of the jazz
uh and when she said that it was
honestly one of the most profound
experiences of my professional career
because i saw someone who had
transcended ownership
and i think one of the things that if
we're not careful
everything that we own can turn around
and own us
uh
and
um and it can actually be very limiting
uh and it can turn on us and here was
someone who had transcended ownership
she was not
owned by the jazz even though she owned
the jazz and i think it helped me see
that there's something beyond
simply acquiring assets or owning things
it's all about uh that purpose
wow
and so
it's very strange david honestly hearing
you know from somebody whose
job
seemingly is to just help people
accumulate wealth and make the best
decisions to
to optimize
on their function of wealth but here
you're saying well i'm here to ask some
more difficult questions and some of
these questions may be
do you want this why are you doing this
and perhaps your optimization function
is not the trivial one that
i would assume coming into this
conversation right
yeah absolutely and i think you hit on
the on the right
thing you know we
we live in the information age you know
it's all about just needing to acquire
more information and you know we listen
to a podcast like hopefully we'll get
the right information and that'll change
my life and
what i came to realize is that you know
data and information inform
but questions and stories transform and
we live in an information age where
we're just seeking the next bit of data
and yet the reality is
we have our phones have access to
basically the entire sum of human
knowledge
and what do we struggle with knowing who
we are what we value and what we believe
right right yeah yeah and so it's not a
lack of information you shouldn't do all
that no there's no media page for that
no no and so i think it's that questions
and stories you know and you go back and
you know what is the socratic method
it's the it's the process of asking
questions and uh great teachers and
leaders of the past
they didn't know the right information
they knew the right questions to ask and
so a large part of that is just sitting
back
asking yourself
those profound questions asking your
asking those around you those questions
because those
in my experience who make the biggest
impact in life
they know who they are what they value
and what they believe they have a
clarity of purpose and it helps them
with everything from decision making
to
how they choose to spend their time and
their talent and their treasure
who they surround themselves with
um
and it makes life in in in some ways
uh much simpler not necessarily easier
uh
but simpler uh because they have that
clarity and yet in my experience the
vast majority of us we don't know the
answers to those questions
does this impact the way you work
in one way or another does this change
the way that you
work with clients the different
questions you ask the different
processes you go through
yeah absolutely absolutely because to me
purpose and people should always drive
process and planning and we do it the
opposite way right you know i've i was
talking with a group of highly
successful entrepreneurs they had
started multiple different businesses
and things like that
and so i asked them i said how many of
you all would credit the success of your
business
to your articles of incorporation
and they all just laugh they're like
zero percent we equate zero percent of
the success of our business
and i said but you needed it they said
yeah we need it i said but what made you
successful they said we knew we knew the
problem that existed in the world
we knew how we wanted to solve it and we
surrounded ourselves with great people
right it was the the key the keys to me
for a successful business just like a
successful wealth transfer are clarity
of purpose
and quality of people uh
and then you let that drive everything
else
unfortunately in estate planning in
wealth transfer it's all about the money
it's all about the wealth it's never
about preparing people for the wealth
um and so when you miss the why and the
who
uh i don't care how great
you are in the what and the how right
you have the greatest articles of
incorporation in the world if you don't
know what you want to do as a business
you don't have good culture you're not
going to achieve anything by the same
token you have that kind of stuff that's
great and you have really basic
documents you're going to thrive and so
what i realized is at the end of the day
i i can help create a skeletal system
but it's heart and soul that actually
makes a difference
heart and soul that makes a difference
and is that something that you are able
to communicate with with the people that
are working with you because they're
coming to you perhaps with a little bit
with a little bit more strict objectives
of of wealth and tax planning and and
legal things you know that maybe they're
not expecting to be
thinking about these difficult yet you
know at the end most critical questions
that that were positioning here yeah i
think so i mean honestly early on i've
been doing this for 25 years so
initially i worked with that greatest
silent generation
uh they were that
product of the great depression
and world war ii
and uh they felt an obligation to
transfer wealth they saw wealth and
inheritance as an obligation
um but beginning with the boomers the
extras the millennials
people are looking for something more
right it's not just about dumping wealth
down and giving unearned undirected
wealth to the next generation because
they see the negative effects in the
united states the average american
inheritance is consumed in 18 months
so
what people inherit what people build
and create over the course of their life
is on average
consumed by the next generation in 18
months wow yeah and you think okay well
that's true of average americans but not
the high net worth or the ultra high net
worth even among the wealthiest
americans the average half-life
of inherited wealth is eight years
so you you take you say
let's say i hear it uh 50 million
dollars
uh and you say
more than you'd ever need in 24 years
statistically speaking you'd have six
and a half million left of that
uh wow that's just one generation and
it's because
you know in 25 years of doing estate
planning the one thing i've learned is
that we value things based on what they
cost us
and and what something doesn't cost us
anything we just can't value it like
something that comes with with cost um
and
and i think one of the issues that we
have uh
in in in the world today is that we want
to bypass cost right we want things to
be cheap and easy
and when they're cheap and easy they're
just not valued um
like something that comes with cost and
i think that's one of the biggest issues
with inherited wealth is i can transfer
the financial resources i can't transfer
the cost and when i can't transfer the
cost i actually can't transfer the value
and that was one of the things that i
had to learn about estate planning
well
how do you take this to your own sort of
career and your own path
you know this question of of the why you
know what what is your why
yeah so um you know what's funny is i
was looking at these um
these characteristics uh and several
years ago my partner and i wrote a book
called entrusted and in there we
identified the key characteristics of
families that successfully transfer
wealth and
um
and and to me that starts with an
understanding of your core values you
know what are your core values what
drives you what motivates you and i'm
writing this and i'm thinking geez i'm a
lawyer i don't even know what values i
have heck maybe i don't even have values
right uh and so i sat down and it went
through a process uh to understand that
and so i kind of
i kind of use five words that drive me
and it's uh think create relate give and
move you know i love thinking i love new
ideas
uh i love creativity
uh
uh so i always try to combine thinking
and creating
um i i think um
relating and being with people if
ultimately if what you do is does not
positively impact others
it's really not worth it um at the end
of the day it's just self-indulgence
um and then giving i think generosity is
such a key component to life
the happiest most engaged people that
i've ever met are the most generous you
know have you ever met a sour upset
uh
depressed generous person
i've never seen it no
i and then move i
love being on the move i love going on
trips i love seeing what's around the
corner uh so that's how i try to engage
with the world and i try to try to check
as many of those boxes as i can each day
i just love how you are
how you're asking all these these super
interesting questions and
sort of you know you've gotten all the
data points throughout the 25 years and
it came with you set up more than 6 000
clients so you really did get to see you
know different people in different
positions and how they think through
their wealth and how they think through
their life and then how they train and
what it also sounds like is you're
touching on this this very delicate
notion of how do you treat
this asset how do you treat this wealth
and how do you what is sort of their
relationship with their wealth and how
big of a part is it of who they are
versus what they need versus what they
want and so
you sort of have a different
data set than what
anybody else maybe has
because you're seeing them in a
different light and so uh
david i really want to thank you for for
joining me this was really fantastic
yeah anytime i really appreciated it
continue making a great impact and stay
safe and stealthy
all right thanks you too
[Music]